c'est une longue route à découvert qui
mène à barmut celle de tous les dangers
dans le ciel un avion de chasse lâche
des leurs pour éviter des tirs de
missiles russes Ukrainiens difficiles à
dire les deux bombards de la zone ce
véhicule a été stoppé net par un obus
dans le centre l'artillerie gronde
baroute survie sous un déluge permanent
de feu le cadavre d'une femme recouvert
à la harpe n'a pas été enlevée trop
risqué nous nous dirigeons vers le
carrefour
des belles siffles
il faut faire demi-tour
c'est ce que vivent quotidiennement les
habitants
nous avons rendez-vous avec les pompiers
la caserne est protégée par quelques
sacs de sable dérisoires
la plupart des soldats du feu sont
partis ils étaient 60 avant la guerre
ils ne sont plus que 10 Volodia est à
quelques mois de la retraite mais il a
choisi de rester aujourd'hui c'est la
guerre que vous combattez il en faut du
courage pour faire ça aujourd'hui à
darkmouth
non je fais juste mon métier
difficile pour lui d'en dire plus
on protège les gens
ne me touchent pas rester vivant
les conditions de vie sont rustiques la
nuit dernière il faisait moins 21 degrés
entre deux interventions le temps
s'écoule lentement
avec toujours l'écho des obus
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est comment il y a
beaucoup de détonations
parce qu'ils sont encore dans la
banlieue alors
alors les pompiers volontaires partiront
laissant derrière eux quelques milliers
de personnes sur les 80 000 que côté bar
mout avant la guerre
dans le centre-ville il ne reste que
trois magasins ouverts dont le rubis un
bazar un peu boutique de lingerie
mercerie et désormais alimentation
cette vieille dame achète le calendrier
j'ai choisi celui avec un chat et un
lapin pourquoi
comment ça pourquoi parce que j'aspire à
vivre dans la paix et la liberté et on
aura ça cette année
pourquoi vous restez je ne sais pas je
ne peux pas abandonner les miens
mes parents je les ai sortis d'ici mais
moi je ne veux pas partir à chaque fois
que je quitte la ville pour acheter des
marchandises je pense très fort à tous
ceux qui restent ici ce sont les miens
[Musique]
vous aussi tous tous tous tous
cela fait 4 mois que des combats
acharnés ont lieu ici et pourtant la
prise de la ville ne représente pas un
intérêt stratégique ce serait pour les
Russes une victoire symbolique mais pour
l'heure aucun des deux camps ne semble
prêt à faire taire les armes